now I'll admit this is quite a hard
question too
to even get into in terms of what's a
way that I can conceive of this that
then I can start to apply conditions to
to do the subsequent questions okay but
once you have that it kind of starts to
spill out a little bit so maybe you'll
be able to help me
once we've got a common concept for this
so here's the first thing I'm going to
do I'm trying to work out what am i
choosing what am i arranging what's
going on here okay so in order to come
up with like a framework for how to do
this I want to think about well how
would I describe the different ways how
could I tell one way from another right
now how what might be one of the paths
through here okay well here's a path
there we go that is one of the paths
right now how would you tell someone if
you know you see this you all can see
this now but you want to communicate to
someone outside the room this particular
part as opposed to for instance say this
path these are two different parts they
arrive at the same spot but how would
you describe them to someone what
language would you use say the black one
how would you describe Ellen
you can't just tell them get from A to B
cuz either black or blue would do that
can someone tell me how would you
describe black to distinguish it from
blue anyone navigated anywhere recently
you're starting to learn and drive right
you need to give someone directions yeah
you need to provide someone directions
because you can get you can get to
Trevor village you know via New Line
Road or via Shepherds buek you around
the back if you wanted okay
you would have to describe like a series
of turns and directions and so on and
you can do the same thing here country
like with the black path right what's
the very first thing that you do you go
to the right you say right and then
after you're right you go down and then
you go right again and then you go down
down down and then I think we alternate
all the way to the end is that right
right down right down is that okay
alright now you describe to me it's an
easy one how do you describe the blue
path
you you get out you get out that that
cold song whenever like do and they were
promoting that that was really cheesy
right you go down oh no no no that and
you do that how many times six times to
get all the way to bottom and then you
do all the rights how many four of them
okay now these are two different paths
through here and obviously there are
many many more okay but now that I've
got a way to articulate what is
happening right can you see I can use
these as a framework for now putting
some numbers down right you are
rearranging some objects what kinds of
objects well how many objects are you
rearranging each time how many steps
must you take to get to the end every
time count them up the number of ways or
the number of steps you've got to go
rather is you've always got to go four
to the right at some point have a look
at them one two three four okay
and you always have to go down how many
times six times right one two three four
five six it doesn't matter where you
drew them but you've got to do them
eventually okay
so you've got six of those four of these
how many in total are you doing ten
objects and you're rearranging them how
many ways are there to rearrange ten
object 10 factorial but of course we're
drastically over counted if we just say
10 factorial because there are many
repeated letters right
how many European to that is either
there are six and four six downs you can
do and for writes you can do so I can
rearrange the downs this way and I can
rearrange the rights this way right hey
by the way we have done we have notation
for this that can get us there quickly
oh just that this is 10 C 6 or you could
also call it 10 C 4 okay now this will
give us an answer I think it's what 200
and 210 there you go right but I'm
interested in like I didn't think of it
as this to begin with
can you tell me a story for how this is
equivalent to say this
to create all the different parts right
you always have to take ten steps right
always have to take ten steps so let me
just draw out ten steps right one two
three four one two three four there we
go ten steps okay now some of these have
to be down oh sorry some of these have
to be right steps how many of them have
to be right steps come on Finn or help
me out how many of these ten steps have
to be to the right to the right
have a look it's always the same number
every time four of them have to be to
the right right thank you Shalini
goodbye through four of them you have to
pick four right choose four say this one
and this one and this one and why not
this one right you've got how many
choices for where you can put those
right with steps I mean like is there
any restriction on where I put them can
I put them anywhere I can right so any
of those ten are fine and you have to
choose how many of them to be right
steps we've got to choose four of them
right so can you see why it's also ten
see six you don't have to place the
right steps you have to choose spots you
could push his way to put the down steps
of which there are six does that make
sense you with me so there you go 210
10cc x10 say for both of them fine